that's my tough-looking warrior that's
what I'm talking about get out there and
make me proud do you ever wonder what if
what if mallanna never became chief
what if arendelle was destroyed what if
our favorite Disney movies were
completely different these deleted
scenes reveal entirely new endings and
characters that never made it to the big
screen but would he have made the movies
better or worse from the frozen to
ending that almost was to the weird way
Remy was supposed to cook and
ratatouille
these Disney deleted scenes show us a
whole new world onward he gives us a
touching look to two brothers who bond
trying to bring their father back to
life for a day but did you know that
there was almost a third main character
Jenny a satyr and waitress at the
manticores tavern was originally
supposed to join the brothers on their
journey she was going to be their
fantasy guru until the writers decided
that they didn't really need her instead
Varley took over the role of fantasy
buff one scene that was cut featured
Jenny and the brothers mean a few sirens
it turns out that sirens and onward act
exactly like real estate agents except a
lot more dangerous they can basically
get anyone to give them anything the
scene was eventually cut because the
sirens were just too dangerous for a
kids movie and then later Jenny was also
cut from the movie and barley took the
wheel as the biggest fantasy fan but
including Jenny would have totally
changed up the movie maybe it would have
felt more like a road trip with friends
than a family bonding opportunities
Jenny may never be officially animated
but at least we can check out the
animated storyboard online to see what a
journey with Jenny would have been like
the ending of frozen 2 was originally
supposed to be a lot sadder instead of
Anna and Elsa meeting by the water to
celebrate saving arendelle Anna was
supposed to meet her sister so that they
could comfort each other about the water
wiping out the city in this version on a
never makes it to the dam on time and
Elsa and Anna have to try and think of
how they can restore their flooded city
this Indian came so close to happening
but they actually animated the flood
water hitting the city but at the end of
the day they decided that it was a bit
too sad and they won
and the movie on a more hopeful note who
could you imagine how different things
would have been if arendelle was
destroyed Aden Elsa would have had to
return together to restore their village
and Elsa may never have gotten the
chance to take over as spirit of the
forest and it probably wouldn't have
been the best time for Kristoff to
propose but if you are curious about
what could have been in a darker version
of the frozen timeline then you can find
the full animated storyboard of the
deleted ending online the live-action
Mulan may have been delayed but Disney
did let it slip that one juicy scene has
already been cut from the movie his
knees been pretty upfront about changes
they're making to the flick the first is
that it's not a musical and the second
is that we won't get to see Mushu or
cricket but the third major change is
that there's no shame however that
doesn't mean Mulan won't have a love
interest in the new movie instead a new
character chen hong Hui will take over
as the man Mulan gets a crush on while
she's training for the army but their
romance won't be much of a big deal on
screen Disney had to delete a scene that
features a kiss between the two
characters Disney just really wants to
focus on Mulan being a warrior not on
her needing a man even with these
changes Disney promises Mulan will
capture the magic of the original we'll
have to wait and see if we miss the kiss
or if it's for the best
and if we get lucky Disney might even
add the deleted scene to Disney Plus
once the movie finally makes its way to
the streaming service
I don't judge people on their worse
mistakes it's hard to think back on how
Natasha sacrificed herself in Avengers
endgame and not to be a little sad but
did you know that Natasha's original
ending was much worse in a deleted scene
that you can stream on Disney Plus
Natasha and Clint are fighting Panos
lackeys on Bohr more as they try to get
the soul stone each of them fights to
get close enough to the edge of the
cliff to sacrifice themselves if the
same idea as the original but as Natasha
dives for the cliff's edge and sees
Thanos drawing closer she throws herself
off and we see the horror on Clint's
face this is so much worse than the
original because the two never get a
moment of closure and Clint doesn't have
much time to take in what just happens
because Thanos is still coming both
scenes have the same result but Hawkeye
might have had a lot more trouble
dealing with Natasha's sudden and
emotional loss if they never really got
to say goodbye
do you prefer Natasha's original ending
or the touching moment we get to see
between her and Clint let us know what
you think in the comments from the first
few minutes of Moana we already know
that she's destined to be chief she's
being trained by her father and she's an
only child there will come a time when
you will stand on this peak and place a
stone on this mountain in the first
draft of the story Moana had six older
brothers that's right six in this
version Murano would have had to earn
the right to become Keith instead of one
of her brothers the plan was probably to
have her return the heart of defeating
with the help of Maui and earned her
spot as top dog but the riders
eventually decided that focusing on her
story as an only child would be much
more interesting still we can't help but
wonder what mallanna's brothers would
have looked like and what kind of songs
the family would have belted out
together on the open sea her brothers
would have likely played a pretty
important role in Moana story somewhere
along the way but for now we'll have to
let our imaginations run wild with
thoughts of what bow Ana's life would be
like with six siblings the live-action
remake of Aladdin had a few deleted
scenes on blu-ray and DVD like an entire
song called desert moon performed by
jasmine
but one of the coolest has to be the
scene where we see some of the worst
wishes genies past masters have ever
made I could just make you a prince Oh
No
right you'll be snuggled up with that
dude for the rest of your life we get to
see how a man wishing to be irresistible
to women
leads to him getting chased how one man
blows himself up after wishing to hold
the power of the universe and how
another man accidentally turns himself
to gold the scene would have made for
some great cautionary comedy about
what's to come later in the movie from
characters making poorly thought-out
wishes we're looking at you too far
and even though Aladdin is a pretty good
wish maker and doesn't need the extra
pointers we definitely would have
appreciated the visuals
Miguel's first introduction to Hector
and Coco was supposed to go down a lot
differently entering the afterlife can
be pretty overwhelming so there were a
lot of ideas floating around about how
exactly Miguel would make his way
through the city one idea was to have
Hector be a celebrity tour guide on a
train this was supposed to be how Miguel
first meets him and also how Hector was
supposed to get Miguel to Ernesto dela
Cruz the team completed a storyboard of
the scene where Hector tells me geld the
rules of the afterlife but the role just
seemed too official for Hector and the
writers wanted to show off his trickster
ways if they had gone with the idea of
tour guide Hector the whole story could
have been totally different
Miguel might have never taken the same
path to Ernesto or ran into the same
characters and we would have gotten to
see Hector in an entirely new light the
blu-ray and DVD release of this film has
a hectare scene available for you to
enjoy as well as other deleted scenes
including an entire opening song called
Dia de los Muertos he's the one behind
these recipes he's the cook the real
cook Rama's creative cooking technique
from ratatouille is unforgettable but
the rat almost did things a whole lot
differently the first version of Remy
teaching linguini how to cook involved
the rat hiding in kitchen drawers
linguini would pass some spoons and
spice and Remy would do the work this
version is a lot more subtle than Remy
hiding under linguini chef hat but it
wasn't nearly as helpful as the anime
hoped a little more time at the drawing
board ended with them putting Remy in a
chef's hat and having him to Linguini's
hair to guide him around the kitchen
this new technique made the movie
funnier and developed the relationship
between linguini and Remy since they
were always stuck so close together it's
crazy to think that the iconic scenes of
Remy almost getting discovered under the
enormous chef's hat almost never were
but the deleted scene is available
online and on the DVD bonus disc if you
want to see Remy try a skill at cooking
before the animators discovered his real
secret hiding place one of the standout
new characters and finding Dory is Hank
the octopus well technically Septimus
but Hanks motivations were supposed to
be a lot different in the deleted
version jewelry doesn't go to quarantine
and instead ends up in the octopus
exhibit where she finds herself trapped
in Hanks tank Hank still decides to help
her but it's because he wants this
strange blue fish out of his personal
bubble not because he wants to escape
the aquarium Hank also has an
interesting quirk in this version of
things as he tries to help Dory find her
family he carries out a bottle of hot
sauce this hot sauce addiction was
supposed to be fun but it's turned
annoying fast when the animators had to
find a way for an octopus to constantly
have a bottle of hot sauce with him the
hot sauce was cut and Hank was given his
desire to escape and the rest is history
the deleted scene can be found on
blu-ray and DVD so you can take a look
and imagine what Hank would have been
like if he hadn't kicked the hot sauce
habit for good
Wally's ending will go down in Disney's
history as one of the most emotional
scenes ever but the movies first ending
was a lot different and pretty much
hated by fans
Wally's original ending was so close to
being the final version of the film that
it was actually completely animated and
aired as test screenings
it featured Eve getting hurt in the
airlock instead of wall-e a tense moment
follows where you wonder if Eve will
make it as Wally tries to repair her but
then she does and the movie seems pretty
much over this ending just didn't have
the emotion the audience wanted so did
decided to take the film back to the
drawing board after some thought they
came up with the version we know and
love
it's a powerful ending where all the
characters come together and wall-e
realizes what makes him special we
honestly can't imagine the movie ending
any other way but the alternate ending
is available online if you want to take
a peek and see what it could have been
and while we wouldn't want to replace
the original an alternate version of
wall-e that centers on Eve would be
pretty cool which deleted scene is your
favorite and which one are you happy got
cut let us know your thoughts in the
comment section down below don't forget
to hit that like button and subscribe to
the things for more of your favorite
content thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time